if you ever have a situation in the
ocean with a shark face the shark I
don't care what your instincts tell you
face the shark cuz it's Predator prey
and if a lion gets spotted it changes
the game no different with sharks they
do these experiments to film and show
the Sharks 20 30 yards away they swim
away splashing shark comes up at them
quick yeah as soon as they turn around
and face a shark it goes to about half
the speed and calms down cuz things that
are splashing in the ocean look like
they're dying and they're the cleaners
of the ocean so they're just after
anything that's erratic so you got to
like somehow pull together and be calm
and see a shark and face it